so after I cheated on my husband I gave
him a hall pass but here's the reason
why I did that is because I didn't want
to take the responsibility of getting
rid of all demons that I opened up my
marriage to and usually this is what
people do when they cheat they want
their other their spouse to cheat on
them back so it would give them a reason
to feel better in some way but let me
tell you that's the wrong way to do it
it's the wrong way to go about it
because at the end of the day you make
matters worse
and even though I knew that that option
was put forth in front of me I knew that
wasn't the right choice that's not the
way that we try to rebuild a marriage if
you want to stay in a marriage that's
still on a downfall and just ride it out
downhill that's up to you if you want to
make that choice but I was not about to
make that same choice if I know I also
have another option of getting back in
the face of God praying for my marriage
praying for my wife and trying to do the
things and correct the wrongs that we
had